les deux premières étapes nous avons
même de vivre et martiniquaise et nous
avons comme on dîne également un maillot
jaune qu'on connaît bien le club
l'équipe de france occitane se révèle
finalement cet après midi oui cet après
midi son horizon ils ont gagné le
contre-la-montre en contre ce sont de
bons coureurs
peut-être qu'ils n'avaient pas encore
récupéré du voyage et demain on verra
bien que ce qu'ils vont faire quoi quand
on regarde bien entre hier et
aujourd'hui on a une moyenne de l'ordre
de 40 km c'est beaucoup pour les suisses
martin avoue ce ça veut dire que le
sexisme ordinaire en progresser ils ont
fait une bonne préparation et volatil
pendant la préparation paye la moyenne
et les lacs pour confirmer le progrès du
segment technique
comment voyez-vous maintenant l'étape de
le dit que jamais notre qualité alors ce
n'est pas très dur parce que là
normalement être unitaire de 24 unités
aulas mercredi
et là maintenant nous entrons le lundi
ce qui veut dire que nous autres dans le
vif du sujet dans la montagne très tôt
et ce sera très dur parce que nous avons
justement en fin de course nous avons
d'estrada monte donc là il y aura des
dégâts